hello there it's finally here the long
promised video explaining relative
positional embeddings
as they were introduced in prehistoric
times by our ancestors in machine
learning
so if you are not yet sick of positional
embeddings in transformers and want
more of them you are spending your
coffee break with the right video
because well we did a video about
positional embeddings as
introduced by the attention is all you
need paper
then we had a video about concatenating
versus adding positional encodings
and there we also discussed learned
positional embeddings
miss coffee bean is now literally 50
caffeine and 50
positional information let's begin the
attention is only need paper introduces
positional embeddings that encode the
absolute position they encode the exact
order of tokens such that the
transformer is informed about the
sequential nature of data
otherwise the transformer that is
processing everything in parallel would
be invariant to order meaning that
without positional encodings its output
would not
change after complete sequence
reordering
but what if we are dealing with other
kinds of data where it is not about
absolute position but about relative
positions
think about a graph for example it would
be quite
arbitrary to say that a certain node is
the first one
what would make this node the first node
and this the second
that would be unmotivated for many
problems and in some cases even
misleading
then let's forget about absolute order
and move to relative positional
encodings that are about the distances
between
elements in either a graph or a sequence
which is in fact a degenerate graph a
chain
a subset of the authors of the attention
is already need paper
also have a follow-up paper doing
exactly this
they introduce relative positional
encodings where not the order but
the relation or better said the relative
position
the distance between tokens is important
so how does this work
if you do not know anything about
positional embeddings
first go and watch our two videos about
them and then come back
don't worry they're short the idea of
relative embeddings is moving away from
the classical positional embedding where
each token has its own positional
embedding
with relative representations each word
or token does not have only
one positional embedding but as many
positional embeddings
as there are tokens in the sequence in
order to describe the
relationship between them this is
because relative positional
representations do not encode
absolute order anymore but the
positional
relationship in which each token stands
to
the other tokens so let's take
an example sequence of five tokens in
classical positional embeddings
each token let's say x4 here
has one encoding informing the
transformer about the position of x4
now to best visualize relative
representations let's copy the sequence
again
like this in the relative variant each
token has
five position embeddings one embedding
for describing its relative position to
itself
then for others for the rest of the
sequence and to keep the same notation
as the original paper the positional
embedding describing the relationship
of one token with itself is a vector
w0 as 0 is the distance between
the token and itself then w1 and w2
as we move to the right and w minus 1
w minus 2 and so on as we move to the
left
and the vector wi takes the same value
independently of what tokens we are
currently looking at
because w0 wherever we are says that we
are at zero hops away in the graph w1
says that we are one hop away to the
left
in a sequence or in a directed graph in
general we
go one hop following outgoing edges
so you see this approach is not made
only for sequences but for graphs too
okay great for a sequence of length five
positional embeddings should range from
w minus four to w4 so we have in total
nine positional embeddings to either
hand craft or
learn for this sequence these w vectors
can be written
one under the other in a table like this
notice that these vectors come from the
relationship or distance between one
token and the other
so we can use a pairwise notation for
this
the authors also experiment with
clipping at k
meaning that after a certain distance
positional embeddings get the same value
so for k equals 2 w3 and w4
all take the value of w2 ok but now for
each token we are
stuck with as many positional embeddings
as the sequence has
tokens what to do with all of these add
them all
up that wouldn't be a great idea
addition is complicating things even
with sinusoidal embeddings
where we have just one positional
encoding for each token
because we could mix up the semantic and
positional information
with five positional embeddings per
token the mixing up problem would be
only five times larger
if only we had a mechanism that given a
token
computes new representations for that
token in relationship to all other
tokens
well we do have this it's the
self-attention mechanism
a clever idea would be to modify the
self-attention formulas to capture the
relative positional representations too
we remember that through self-attention
each token gets a new representation z
which is passed further in the
transformer module
each token vector is first transformed
by a linear transformation
then the new representation for each
token is a weighted sum
over all tokens where the weights
are sort of an important score so
fellow tokens that matter more are
weighted more
so here where the new representations
are computed we can
add the positional information now the
token representation after the linear
transformation
is further shifted in the high
dimensional space
this means that each token xj gets
pushed into a subspace saying
that look i carry this semantic
information
but i'm also your second neighbor to
your right
because my position in some dimension is
similar to
all other second neighbors okay
great now the new representation z is
informed about the relative position
but the self-attention weight
coefficients are not
therefore the weight coefficients also
receive their
own positional push such that the
important scores
make position informed decisions too
so what do we have in the end now every
token has as many
relative embeddings as there are tokens
in the sequence
in two variants one relative embedding
for the values
and one for the keys to inform the
attention weights
and the exact values of the vectors are
learned
which kind of makes sense to let the
model figure out for itself what the
best balance
is it would be quite difficult to
handcraft all of these
and what did this whole thing help with
well this paper has only experimented
with text which is a sequence obviously
and they gain some performance in
machine translation
but word chains are only a flat graph
and beyond this the method can be
applied
to graph representations in general or
anywhere where you have
pairwise relationships between your
elements because
remember these relative representations
depend only on how
far tokens are from one another
independently of whether we are in a
sequence or in a more complex graph
but with coffee bean why didn't this
paper try this out immediately
well it's called marking your territory
but there are
other papers that implemented this
successfully for graphs too
anyway another upside of relative
positional representations
is that especially with clipping at k
this learned positional information
generalizes to
any sequence length which is also a
feature of the
handcrafted sinusoidal embeddings but
not necessarily of
any learned positional embedding
clipping at k
seems a little odd because with small k
it takes away the information of long
term dependencies
now we can only store that something is
close by
or far away but we don't know how far
away
that is but this is similar with graph
neural networks where the best results
are delivered with a small number of
iterations
many iterations allow for information
from further away to diffuse to
your point of interest but multiple hops
are not always beneficial as it can
aggregate noisy signals from far away
so clipping at k in relative positional
representations
acts a little like a relative position
event horizon
which does not hurt tasks which mostly
rely on local dependencies
well we hope that these relative
embeddings and the associated paper
are now more digestible to you thanks
for staying until the end of this
explanation
and if you're still here do not forget
to leave a like and subscribe
you know to help with the youtube
[Music]
algorithm